each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it is my pleasure to introduce my gang
today she is been interning with us here
in Mike's her research connections this
summer she's from University of
Rochester upstate New York her research
interests are in signal processing
mobile communication sensor networks and
this summer she is actually developed a
unique sensor for the mobile windows 7
mobile phone over to yang thank you hi
everyone my name is Nayan it's my
pleasure to have it all of you here
today to come to my presentation it's my
great pleasure and the phone application
I derive during the summer is called
listen and a few so it's a mobile
emotion sensor which can detectives
emotion based on how you speak to the
phone it will use signal processing and
the cloud computing and my mentor at MSR
is arguments and new okay um here the
the last chance I do my introduction
here I come from University of Rochester
which is a very cold place you can see
from the left left left picture there
lot of snow during the winter and my
advisor at school is windy hanselman
from this picture you can see that's a
beautiful view from the top of my campus
and in my spare time I like playing peop
so if there are any questions or any
concerns you can count on me through my
email address so any press cheon's that
will come during my presentation okay
here's a line oh I will explain how we
come up with this idea to develop
develop this emotion sensor and how we
implement it on the cloud and will I
will sum up with challenges and a future
work and of course the fo brother phone
here so you can see the time
and you can try that okay so nowadays
phones out used everywhere and anytime
and there are a lot of sensors which
enable the phone to be a very convenient
tool and also a daily company to us we
can see there are microphone cameras and
on the right side that's a accelerometer
so if you move your phone it will detect
movement and also the GPS which will
tell you your location and also the
geometer so if you just remove your
phone or turn it around so it also can
feel that difference in position also
besides those sensors they are another
kind of sensor which can help monitor
our physical condition like the new
prototype and develop I rim which code
BlackBerry's empathy which can detect
all the the users heart rate blood
pressure and all these physical
condition using a very magic a little
rain here but will come up with the
question about the useless emotion
physical condition is important but
sometimes emotion will be more important
which is our which can tell us inside
word so let's begin from the very
beginning what is motion so from a
definition emotion is the
psychophysiological experience of an
individual state of mind as interacting
with biomedical which is the internal
factors and also environmental which is
the external factors so the reason why
we want to deploy the sensor around the
phone is that we want to detect emotion
in a mobile fashion wear anywhere and
anytime and also people may feel that it
may be they are not very willing to tell
their real emotion to the outside world
or to another person so but then if
you're comfortable talking to their own
phone so we would like to
use of this point to just let the user
to talk to their own phone and then the
phone will know the real emotion it will
be much easier for some there at least
some user cases here so you can even see
that phone can be the emotional sense
around the phone freedom boy can be used
in citizen science project so some of
you here may not have heard that but
that's a very popular citizen science
projects happening now which the very
normal citizens can take participate in
citizen project to help scientist or
health social psychology some other
scientists in other research field to do
some very simple science project by
collecting data so let's a crowd enabled
project so by using our emotions answer
on phone we can help scientist in
psychology or sociology to with ample
current data and the test which city has
the most highest happiness index or
which factors will influence people's
emotions for them poor people will feel
much happier at home versus at work so
that's a very interesting point to study
also a health care because it hard to
know people's emotions so patient with
illness mental illness may not be
willing to tell their counselor or
doctor about their real mood so the
doctors can put this motion sensor on
the phone to do this morning all the
time also the network's imagine that you
can like a photo or a message or the
status of your friends by using your
wife so if you speak to the phone like
wow that's amazing and then the to
transmit this message ultimately to
Facebook or tutor to post to all our
friends so that will be very cool thing
also we can because social networks give
us an opportunity to get a lot of data
from a large population
so we can also make use of this to
analyze the motion of the certain
population and also games an ensemble of
the intern here already cut your kin egg
and Xbox so imagine if you can play an
xbox game which you can influence your
emotion on the character you're playing
so that will be extremely cool so by
using your wise so the key neck or the
Xbox machine will listen to your mood
but listening to your wise so it can be
on the phone or on the connect or other
sensors and finally you can customize
your phone imagine your phone we will
change the sound or the same color based
on the mood based on your current mood
so which will make the phone more lovely
here some today in the Android or iPhone
market there are already some motion
detection application all they are but
they don't used in they're not used in
the scenarios I've talked before or
neither do they have very strong
scientific background and so that the
men difference and also t connect
there's no emotion center on to connect
but there are some very simple speech
recognition which you can give very
simple comment so that the different
show how we stand out ok here comes the
meat so the phone application is to look
like this and I will show that later so
we'll press a button your voice the
whole audio wave file will be
transmitted upload to a server and cloud
and and we'll do some signal processing
to try the speech features of that voice
so it does not try to understand what
you're saying but how you say that word
or a truant or sentence and those
features will be used at the test data
to input to a learning machine so we can
see there on the other side the server
are also works of line which tries to
extract all the speech features from a
large database with over 1000 dealer
samples with no so there are speeches
with no emotion we also do the same
things tracked the speed features from
all this data samples and then you'll
the same machine learning algorithm
which is called a large st regression to
to train the system and get the weight
so with the impact data and wait at the
ua input we can output the pre
dailymotion and at a table later how
what the database we use how we do the
signal processing and also how we do the
Martian learning okay here the database
um i will show you some samples so the
speakers are actors or actress they just
did he'll speak a newt remaining
sentence addresses that a number or the
date with ample pride June twentieth
June twentieth October fifth October
thin 508 508 another one elation 810 810
I'm here 810 five hundred to five
hundred to five hundred to so motion on
the left side are both happy the heavy
emotions and emotions on the red side
are used as sad emotions for them for
despair November night November night
now hear different 4006 4006 performed
by 71 or sanic August second jun 28 jun
28 to give you some sense of how the
cleaner data we use so we have all the
features needed here in total 12
features in the frequency domain and
also in the energy domain so
all the features we get because feel and
hope each the pH changes a lot we must
speak so that's a bunch of ph values so
we get the whole vector and then
calculate the mean value max minimum
standard deviation median and range all
these statistic values so all this 2772
metrics are used at our the risk factor
or the features okay here comes some
signal processing sense um so given
waveform will because they are digital
sampled so for example if the amplitude
is above a certain threshold will mark
it as one so here the sample marker
listed here and then for a bunch of
markers will set a friend with the last
100 millisecond so we do the signal
processing for them protection energy
calculation within that frame and then
we have this frame marker so but you can
see there's a little gap here because
the amplitude verse of very low so it
may not be very accurate to know the
exact pitch a pitch value so it doesn't
make sense to cover the pitch so that it
will just totally run our without so
we'll just do the signal processing in
these friends with freemarker equals to
1 and here this slide show the the noise
reduction so before the noise reduction
we can see the pitch there are some
backbone background noise but after that
we'll see them you know waveforms pretty
smooth okay here come the first feature
pitch so here is the kind of a relative
high knees or lowness of the tone as
perceived by the ear so for example
women speakers tend to have a higher pH
than men we the pitch calculation
algorithm will yield is in the
domain which is called autocorrelation
freedom pole for this utterances we can
see peter behrens a lot so each assemble
here is the frame marker which the
amplitude of the free marker detect
shows the peach value when it is high or
low the second feature is energy so for
within each frame we get the summation
of all the square value of the sample
amplitude of the sample marker which
will be used at the energy value of that
frame so we can see you can also see
from the amplitude of the wave form so
energy is all about their oh you bet the
absolute value ok last one informant so
format is the it's generated by the
vocal tract your innocence so I'll show
later how the human spirit is generated
so Foreman is generally the gain in your
in the speech in their frequency domain
not the the pulses but they are shaped
with ups and downs so all this by this
moment so with this game we can get the
oval peaks which are determined which
are defined as the formant frequency and
also we use the three DB bandwidth so
the algorithm will use to get the cat
format is called linear predictive
coding so from from the samples we came
here they are shaped as and dance with
the format kind of again and then we can
have ups and downs in those sample
markers so the pictures above it the the
the final speech signal will see in the
fruit Z domain so the other way around
what we see is the signal like this in
the front seat oh man
do we need to get again from from the
signal which is not measured but if it
is not measured but you right from the
amplitude in the fruit seed oh man okay
so here are all the features at how
about so this slide shows the machine
learning algorithm called largest fear
aggression so I know some of you are in
the machine learning area so this is a
very simple machine learning algorithm
because it's a linear that's a bunch of
risk factors which are the features we
use they are weighted by beta which is
called the regression coefficient so the
old form of the input that is V and V is
the output can be calculated by using
the function the regression function
shown valve so this function will output
a value between either 0 or 1 between 0
1 which give us the probability of
occurrence of an event so you can see if
the weight is pretty high or very low it
will show how strong or weak it will
influence the final outcome for them
both from the simulations we did we can
see that energy and peak range influence
a lot on the outcome and the position of
our algorithm is in tested through a
method called cross validation and the
outcome is around 71 percent so
something why is covered by all the
values that calculate crack predicted
correctly divided by the total sample
okay from the demo time so here the
button bar with the required but until a
stop and the few button which is little
hard um
Lucas switch to the protector thank you
so here the phone I'll make sure it okay
so we can see here the with a little
hard that the listener field application
so in the Start screen we can see the
you can record recording-wise villain
Paul let me give you an example first
keep quiet I'm really happy today that
is the press stop then we can press a
few button which the Odin will file will
be uploaded to the server and it's
processing now you can see you have a
good mood um ok let me try beer oh no
which is sad hopefully can give him the
credit answer
oh ok it is to have you today
recommendation so Anna still want to try
that f and if you want to try this demo
you can try to yourself okay so do it up
there so that people get okay i won my
voice is a little scratchy today so I'm
feeling a little under the weather today
I might have been too happy oh yeah
prezzo feel better
hey I'm not have our happy today all
right let me try to be with me today is
a great day well the knife
oh well let me try one more time I'm
having an excellent day today oh yeah
they might just be the same maybe the
page of them mails okay great hahaha
thank you we're free yeah so am I want
to try that again okay yeah before you
can play with it after the presentation
hi can we switch back to the laptop okay
cool so dear how this app is working
with just demoed it so to summarize the
challenges I think the the most chatham
harder face is how to setup the server
on the cloud so we'll use windows
communication foundation to do the
communication between the phone and the
and the server and also how to set all
this configuration correctly with ample
the flower war proxy and Internet
Information Service which hosts the
service and also there are a lot of
access control issues when you deal with
the server you need to get a permission
to access a file or change the file and
also to pull all the components gather
is the Oval if it is another challenging
part because as I show in the
architecture there are a lot of sample
signal processing and how to design a
phone application and also how to setup
the server how to you need to learn and
implement machine learning algorithms so
all this stuff makes the whole system
work so that I think that's a beauty of
engineer being an engineer okay some
social work in the future we need to
create more data like this to test on
users and then we need to compare the
performance with other platforms with a
full ample apple iphone or android also
in future will publish as a conference
paper for also we need to improve the
position in different ways for example
to improve the future extraction
algorithm based on the existing features
or we can do my internship I also talked
with some profile some researchers in
the communications field so they also
give some very good recommendation for
them poll to use the mouse frequency
capsule coefficient so we can try that
feature as well also we can try out the
machine learning algorithms and also um
one thing that we can use the user data
we crack it as a new training data to
improve to the tuning system so weeks by
that we can get a better result when we
have more training data sort of ways to
refine the app freedom poll only one
user can exit the app now but if we
published on the market on which we
should expect that more users can access
the application simultaneously so the
server needs to kill all this request
and handle that and also we need to
another and I think that we can see the
application if it takes some time to get
a feedback from the server that because
a lot because we need to upload the
whole audio wave file to the server but
if we can do something no problem just a
locally on the phone and just upload the
future data to the server so that will
reduce the traffic and we can get a
better feedback speed and also we can
add one you surprised the agreement just
one before we play the app so user will
know that their voice will be
transmitted to the cloud also I think in
fact I'm lucky enough to not to do
another internship here next summer
probably I can make this app really
benefit in the society for example we
can use it in a citizen science project
or healthcare
product I think that would be more
meaningful and finally our because the
app is trying to detect people's
emotions but imagine that we can do the
other way around if there's a very plain
sentence but we want to color it with
different emotions so that would be more
interesting for example if you call a
call center so that there's a virtual
person answer as in your phone so it may
feel that's a little bit strange but if
we can curl this conversation with ample
with different emotion so you your you
imagine that as if you are talking with
a real person so that will give us a
better user experience I found the
internship web app so vnms are really
great opportunity because you can really
do something not just to sit in front of
your computer but you can play with
other things like the server yet and so
finally you can just make everything
work which is really wonderful so
actually the first recording i did on
this phone is well that is working with
real emotions really happy so it's not
just the app but everything work so
which really fantastic job and because
my intership is in the connections group
and I want to sincerely thank you for
all of your help during my internship
for any advice or information your you
have provided really great ative will be
quickly appreciated and here the logo
hallelujah the spirit of the connection
group is imagine even inspire and I
really learned a lot from it and also
something about MSR I think really a
super research engine I made a lot of
great researcher and the great interim
friends so I really want to come back to
this cool place like summer not because
the weather but also the great research
yeah I think that's what the reference
and thanks for watching glad to take any
questions you may have yeah without two
helmets I think you are you have to
distinguish it in a mood and emotion and
expression okay vocal expression facial
expressions yeah i think the things that
you can object measure so the
publications this year some of them very
careful they're saying we're taking
facial expressions yeah right that's
something external what you're doing i
believe is vocal expression you're not
emotion because emotions interval you're
not prepared by have this kind of faking
it or not right and then you're mixing
mood and emotion emotion is kind of
transit short-term and water the lawn
type of life and this very complicated
psychological difference in a second
thing is i think i really right now your
machinery is kind of a speaker
independent but you try to use the same
training data and then try to detect the
emotion of vocal expression everyone
and your accuracy is a little bit bigger
than random guessing I don't get a
50-percent and you are chips seventy
percent i think that's that's actually
pretty impressive because people can be
so different in their local expression
so I wonder if you can personalized
detection probably be much more accurate
okay we find the apt to get actually
record from boy from the user itself
therefore very personalized item that we
have in the clock I can train with the
user's life next year you can do it when
you deploy in the marketplace you can
ask people to come for confirm whether
recognition is right enough right they
can use that basic tag that they look
like good work is a lot of fun lot of
work work
yeah question I think that's a great
idea and I'm interested particularly in
your idea of alcohol centers as we all
like you know call it in and then on
hold and all that stuff but what if you
were bursting so the computer can
actually know what kind of mood you're
in opposed to giving motions to the
computer therefore the impure can say
answers like oh I understand your
frustrations point sort of deflating
tension yes I am sort of like a pure way
we have put the more angry customer to
the public you that's why I'm pretend to
be right good point thank you
yeah the console me uh do I know you
showed a couple of potential
applications of it but give any other
plants for making a little more like
ubiquitous it's just a part of the phone
I guess I guess maybe that was part of
the thing Thank You Jimmy yeah yeah yeah
I want to make it actually embedded in
the phone not a standout app for them
poet can constantly monitor or somehow
the conversation the daily conversation
to track how your emotion is changing so
yeah yeah click on the back you kind of
indicated at the beginning when you
showed the samples that you took a
variety of different samples with
different emotion or labels and you've
catalyzed the most to like positive or
negative I was just wondering if you'd
thought about other so they you've done
some kind of high-level mail labeling
but you thought of other ways that you
could kind of label the speeches without
these kind of labels that can kind of be
like pride for instances maybe AB
subjective and
and is loaded with other connotations
but at this other work in emotion which
catalyzes things in terms of valence and
arousal would jerk yeah perhaps a
different way of looking at yeah yay
another way to another way to classify
emotions is to use a quadrant so
emotions can be differentiated in
negative emotions or active or positive
motions like angry or sad negative and
happy and an interest a price they are
positive motions also in other direction
is the active or passive with ample
board or said they are passive but like
happy or angry they are active emotions
so we do have that four quadrant but it
was just a very our prototype so we just
want two different it happy and sad
moment certain place there to damage
yeah yeah yeah why is acting this yeah
yeah it with all the old emotions there
so in the database they are totally 40
motions including the new toy emotion a
lot of comment um you define the problem
as a as a finger up my agent had
classified five years and actually most
of time work emotionless right way to
talk to people I think the problem
probably have been better defined as a
detection of
they can detect unhappiness or hybrids
what this actually I had this
observation from one of the papers I
lubricant on paper they claim to have a
seventeen percent accuracy I mean
recognized emotions but the day they
actually showed seventy-five percent of
time people are emotionless basically
that mean if you just always guess the
sky and emotionless you are cheap
seventy percent accuracy so that's why I
think defined pub the detection problem
maybe it's Morris yeah but of all the
rights it covered there should be a
confident in that to say the person very
angry very angry are very happy or very
sad so if the person okay
and another tarian part of that emotion
is sometimes many concealed with neutral
that's the thing then become the
evaluation metrics become different but
right now you're trying to use a matrix
of classification matrix to to develop a
feature then they become a positive
force positive or negative views
detection
it seemed to may be more accurate if we
want to if we can combine all this
matter together for them po also try to
interpret the conversation for the mode
there may be some keywords to indicate
whether people is is in an active or
passive emotion and also we can combine
the facial expression or the gestures
yeah so maybe Canada will be a would be
the future let's go around